and myself, having experienced and suffered
domestic violence,
I am committed to fighting against any
repression against any discrimination
against women personalities like
denis with a bomb attack and
female genital mutilation at christmas parties and
nasri spots and services by eric roy ya
among the good students at fi l adie
connect life
i think that to stop
female genital mutilation on the
european continent the european union
must be able to ensure and encourage
all members to ratify the
istanbul convention on violence
against women  in general and there is a
section on prevention and
awareness training on
female genital mutilation